[موسيقى]
السلام
عليكم تو بي
باك طبعا بس كذا نبذه بسيطه انا نصي من
الرياض انا نجديه
فلون لما ارجع هنا احس اني انا في بلدي في
يعطيكم العافيه على الاستضافه طيب افلا
يتفكرون فمير تعرفوا الكلمه هذه فين
تشوفوها في القران عمركم فكرتوا فيها
عمركم ت فكرتوا في افلا يتفكرون طيب انا
انا من نوعيه الاشخاص اللي لما اجلس
يسموني ارهق نفسي بس اقعد افكر ايش معنى
ليش صار طب كيف طب السياره كيف تشتغل طيب
الماكينه كيف بتحرك الكفرات طيب اللي تحت
طيب السير حق الشنط في المطارات كيف بشتغل
وكيف واقعد طول الوقت مخي شغال شغال شغال
والناس يقول انت بترهق نفسك انا بالنسبه
لي شايف انها تمرين قاعد افكر في الاشياء
اللي حولي واحاول اوصل لمقصد الشيء هذا
الاسنس الجوهر حق الشيء هذا طبعا افلا
يتفكرون ذكرت في
القران عشر
مرات
ويعقلون ذكرت 20 مره طبعا يعقلون مرتبطه
بشيء يسموه الادراك الحسي بمعنى انه الشخص
لما يشوف شيء طبيعي منطقي زي يقوللك يعني
يا اخي بالعقل تجي فشوف شي منطقي قدامك
هذا ا فتدرك انه الشيء هذا يؤدي الى كذا
او معناته كذا او اصله كذا ين تبدا تفكر
فيه فتحلل وتوصل لاستنتاجات اعتبرها دراسه
اعتبرها بحث معين تفكير تحليلي يسموه او
انيكك القران ذكرها كذا مره ودائما تختم
بها الايات في اغلب الاحيان بمعنى انه هذا
مقصد من مقاصد القران فله سبحانه وتعالى
بيرسل لنا رساله واضحه وصريحه انه لا تعطل
الاله هذه اللي انا معطيك هي وشغلها طول
الوقت طبعا الاله هذه شغاله 24 ساعه حتى
وانتم نايمين شغاله الاحلام اللي بتحلمو
وعلى فكره ترى تحصل احيانا انه تجيني
افكار في الحلم فاقوم اكتب الفكره بسرعه
عشان عاده اذا استنيت 10 دقائق ربع ساعه
يطير
الحلم طيب لما تنظروا الامور حولكم عاده
اذا شفت مشكله ضايقتك اول شيء يجي في بالك
تذمر ابغى اتذمر من المشكله هذه لا اراديه
تبدا تفكر يا الله تاخر العفش في المطار
ايش اللي اخرهم ايش اللي صار يا الله
السياره تاخرت يا الله على زحمه الرياض اف
الشباب اللي يروحوا الملاعب يحضروا مباراه
النصر الاهلي على السيره ولا الهلال
يروحوا قاعدين مثلا ثلاث ساعات اربع ساعات
قبل المباراه تبدا يا الله زحمه مو زحمه
كيف استنى ايش اسوي كل الاسئله هذه كيف
تستعملها انها تحولها لصالحك مو بس نقول
ايجابيه و احنا عارفين ايش يعني ايجابيه
لا تحولها لصالحك بمعنى انك تقدم شيء مبني
على هذه الاشياء كيف تبدا بثلاث خطوات
فاول شيء تاخذ النت او العنصر اللي قدامك
او الشخص اللي قدامك او المشكله
تجدها تبحث عنها في اي مكان حولك ابحث عن
المشكله او الامكانيه يسموه بوتنشل بمعنى
اي مشكله قدامك اي مشكله الحل حقها ممكن
يتحول لفكره او
البوتني دكس واحده من التوكس عظيمه تعرفون
اللي تجي في المواقع لما تحطوا باسورد
يطلع زي ويندو كذا ويقوللك حط الحروف
ملخبطه تعرفوها هذه عرفين فايدتها هذه
فايدتها انه يتاكد انك انت بني ادم يعني
ما انت اله داخله وقاعده تسجل يوزر جديد
فالرجال اللي اخترع الشيء هذا قال طيب
يعني في 40 50 مليون واحد في العالم يوميا
بيضغطوا الارقام هذه كيف اقدر استفيد منها
فعمل مشروع يخلي كل واحد فيكم اليوم او
بكره ياخذ الشي هذا ويكتبه في البوكس اللي
تحت اكشلي هيز ديجيتز بوك بيحول كتاب
لكتاب رقمي عمركم تدروا الشي هذا عارفين
الشي هذا يعني كلنا مشاركين في كتابه كتب
الان صدقه ولا مو صدقه ما عمركم فكرتوا
فيها فالرجل قال اوردي يعني احنا بنبذ
الوقت في الاشياء هذه فحولها الى كتاب
رقمي وصار يصوروا الكتب ويحطوا قطع منها
فكل الناس ينسخوا يحطوا في البوكس مو
عارفين انهم بيكتبوا كتب ما اذكر الرقم بس
حوالي 3 الف كتاب في اليوم
بينكتب بالحركه هذه فتبحث عن مشكله خدمه
منتج انت قاعد في مطعم ما عجبتك الخدمه
فيه قاعد في في عياده حسيت انك تاخرت
والله النظام التعليمي في مشكله في
المدرسه اللي كنت فيها متضايق منه ابحث عن
المشكله حط يدك عليها مثال مشكله دوليه
مشكله انتاج الطاقه ابحاث يا كثرها في
الرنت انرجي او الطاقه البديله طاقه
الشمسيه لا طاقه الماء كيف نبدر نستغني عن
البترول لو خلص البترول معرف ايه مشكله
دوليه اساسيه تقوم عليها صناعات فكيف انت
تقدر تستفيد من خبره عندك او شهاده عندك
او حتى شغف ممكن ما يكون عندك شهاده وتاخذ
المشكله هذه وتبدا تفككها تتفكر فيها
وتحاول توصل لحاجه مشكله ثانيه الانتظار
قبل المباريات في الملاعب هل هذه مشكله
ولا امكانيه طيب انت قاعد ساعتين في
الملعب بتستنى مباراه كيف الساعتين هذه
تحولها لصالحك ممكن انت تفكر على نفسك على
نطاق نفسك ممكن تفكر على نطاق بزنس طبعا
ممكن اعمل مشروع انه الساعتين هذه والله
اركب حاجه في في المقعد يصير فيه شاشه
تعليميه ترفيهيه واروح اتعاقد مع ملاعب
وتصير الشاشه هذه موجوده بالتعاون مثلا مع
وزاره التعليم ولا ما ادري قاعد افكر معكم
ممكن جدا تستغل الساعتين هذه انك تطلع
منها حاجه مفيده مشكله تتحول لحل البطاريه
في الجوالات قبل فتره انا كان في مشروع
اناوي اشتغل عليه كان يخص البطاريات فبحثت
شويه في البطاريات فكان بيقوللك انه
التكنولوجي حق البطاريات شويه صعب انها
تتطور فبدلا ما بفكروا في كيف يطوروا او
يطولوا عمر البطاريه بيفكروا كيف يقللوا
استهلاك الاجهزه الالكترونيه بشكل عام طيب
هذه جانبين لعمله واحده طيب انا كيف اقدر
اطور الجانب هذا هذه امثله نظر لها بالعكس
هذه براندز تعرفوها ستاربكس احد ما يعرف
ستاربكس قهوه عارفين مين انشا
ستاربكس ستاربكس انشوه ثلاث اشخاص متخصصين
في ايش في ايش واحد مدرس تاريخ واحد مدرس
انجليزي واحد كاتب ولا لهم علاقه في
القهوه اصلا حبوها بس يعني عملوا اول مقار
وقت في سياتل وبعدين جاء واحد فنشر كابيتس
عجبته الفكره وهو يحب القهوه اصلا
الايطاليه وقال كيف احولها المعرف ايه شيء
ضخم ابل فنفس الشيء واحد فيجينير عنده
رؤيه طيب فكروا بريكت داون الحين هذه
الاشياء اللي قدامكم احنا نمسك كريم خلينا
نمسك كريم تعرفوا كريم زي اوبر كذا بيحل
مشكله
ايش مواصلات ممتاز صار بزنس ولا ما صار
بزنس طيب ايش فكر فكر والله الناس مو
قادرين يوصلوا لاماكن معينه احيانا ببلك
ترانسبورتيشن مو موجود احيانا السواق غالي
احيانا احيانا كيف اقدر اعمل حاجه سلوشن
حل الحل هذا تاكل زنيد في احتياج فوالله
اعمل تطبيق بضغطه زر اقدر اوصل سياره لشخص
معين ويبدا يشتغل ت اوبتمايزر هذا ستاربكس
بيقدم حل انا ما اعتبره بيقدم قهوه بيقدم
حل القهوه في كل مكان بتجلس انفام منت
حلوه تشرب بتاكل واحده من البوليسي اللي
عندهم اللي تعجبني اللي هي مو لازم تطلب
عشان تقعد هوو شاريك كزبون تعال استريح
اقعد مبسوط يعني حتشتري قهوه في يوم من
الايام ابل سولوشن يعجبك الديزاين ماسكو
اتس كذا شكله حلو وما اعرف ايش والابلكيشن
جواتها حلو فكلها على بعضها صايره
بلاتفورم عظيم تبغى
تستعمله طيب الخطوه الثانيه تشوف الحلول
المتوفره فانت ممكن جدا تكون متخصص في امر
ما وتلاقي المشكله هذه وتبدا تشتغل عليها
تمشي تمشي تمشي وبعدين تبدا تشوف انه في
حلول طب في صناعه يعني كريم لما طلع في
اوبر طب كريم ايش تغير عن اوبر ما اعرف
نروح نسالهم لكنه اكيد اكيد درس اوبر مره
مضبوط ودرس ايزي تاكسي ودرس ودرس ويدور
على المشاكل فعندكم اربعه مجالات تقدروا
تدرسها اساسا الحل متواجد ولا لا اصلا في
ولا لا ممكن ما يكون في يكون موجود في
دوله ثانيه لكن ما موجود في السعوديه اي
مشكله فكر اطلعوا برا الصندوق اي مشكله
ممكن الحين عندكم انت البلوك ما تحاولوا
تفكروا في مشكله او ما انتم قادرين اذكروا
الكلمه هذه لما تتعرضوا لمشكله بدل ما
تقول يا ليت لو يسووا شفت يا ريت لو يسووا
هذه فكره طلعت لا تقول يا ريت لو يسووا
سويها انت امسك الفكره هذه كذا وتمسك فيها
وسويها الشيء الثاني بعد ما تشوف تواجدها
شوف جودتها هل هي ممتازه ممكن المطعم ما
هوو جيد ما عجبني فعاليتها قد ايش مكلفه
ما هي مكلفه سوري جدواها قدش مكلفه ما هي
مكلفه يمكن الكوست حقها عالي زي الطاقه
البديله مشكلتها انه في انتاجها عاده مكلف
جدا فال التكنولوجي كيف نخفض الكوست بعد
بعدين بعد ما تاخذ الاربع الاشياء هذه
اقدر انتج حل جديد او اطور حل اوريدي
موجود وكل واحده فيهم اختراع ترى مو شي
اقل من الثانيه ممكن اخذ الحل ما هو اغير
في شي بسيط يصير يعني وده من الاشياء اللي
قريتها قبل فتره في وحده امريكيه والله
نسيت اسمها عملت
شركه التست تيوب او اللي تاخذ منها تحاليل
الدم عمل التكنولوجي انه الواحد يقدر ياخذ
عين دم اقل بكثير ويعمل عليها تست اكثر
الشركه الحين تسوي حوالي 10 مليار
دولار ليش بس عشان فكرت كيف اقدر اطول حل
اوريدي موجود الشيء الثالث قدم الحل وترى
تقدم الحل هذه ما هي النهايه هذه البدايه
دوبك بدات ترى كلنا عندنا افكار كلنا ما
احد هنا ما عنده افكار وكلنا بنقعد في
الاستراحه نشرب الشاي ونشرب القهوه اوه يا
ليتني اسوي بزنس اوه والله لو انه في مقهى
كذا سويه يا اخي لا تقعد كل يوم تتحلطم
تعيد نفس في السالفه وقاعد مع نفس الشباب
ولا احد بيسوي الفكره هذه سويها ايش ناقصك
ايش معنى نستنى الاشياء هذه تجي من برا
ليه مو ابل يكون شي سعودي يكون اسمه
تفاحه فتاخذ الفكره هذه ابحث فيها طور كيف
تصير ما تصير ممكنه ما هي ممكنه طبقها
وقيمها وهذه دوره ما تخلص تلف تلف تلف تلف
ال ان تقدر توصل لمشروع موجود الان ايش
الوقود للدوره هذه انا اؤمن بحاجه اسميها
شغف اؤمن تماما بالشغف الشغف وقود جيد
ممتاز انك تبدا حاجه لكن الشغف ما يكفي
اذا ما في كومتمنت ما في التزام ترى الشغف
انطفي ما هو شي يقعد لابد الابدين ممكن
جدا واحد بعد خمس سنين شيء كان يحب يعمله
الحين ما يحب ولا يبغى
يسويه اب اعطيكم مثال تعرف تطبيق صورلي او
موقع صورلي فكره جديده ستارت اب بزنس
الفكره
او المشكله اللي شافها لقي انه ما في ما
في تواصل بين المصورين والعملاء شركات ولا
احد يبغى يصور اي حاجه ما في ما في احد
يفلتر الموضوع هذا فقال ليش ما انا اسوي
حاجه الكترونيه اقدر افلتر اجمعهم واجيب
لهم العملاء والدنيا تصير حلوه واخذ نسبه
وفر لهم الحل هذا طبعا شاف السوق في احد
بيعمل الطريقه هذه بطريقه منظمه انا ما
اعرف انا ما سويت البحث بس انا ما شفت اذا
كان موجود تسويقه سيء عشان انا ما اعرف
عنه وقدم المنصه الالكترونيه هذه بحيث انه
يجمع داتا بيس حق مصورين ويجمع داتا بيس
حق كلاينت يربط بينهم بخت موفق راسين
بالحلال صار عنده بزنس البزنس هذا انا
اتنبا انه حيكون شي ضخم ان شاء الله
قريبا ستوب واينن نبطل نشتكي نبطل نشتكي
ونشتغل
يعني احنا احسن شعب في العالم يشتكي
ودائما اضرب مثال بهذاك الشخص اللي كل يوم
يروح يقعد مع الشباب او البنت اللي كل يوم
تقعد مع البنات يا الله س رحت الدائره
الحكوميه الفلانيه ويا الله ساعتين
والموظف ما هو فيه ويوم وصلت وقعدت مه نص
ساعه ققل دقيقه وطالع يفطر وما اعرف ايش
الرجل شغال في دائره حكوميه ثانيه ويرجع
متاخر وينام ويروح متاخر دوم شايفين اللفه
يعني ترى حقوقك واجبات عند غيرك وجباتك
حقوق عن غيرك لفه هي فاشتغل ركز على حاجه
استلهم من النتس اللي حولك خذ مقاصد
القران الله سبحانه وتعالى وفرها وقال لك
فكر في الامور اللي حولك وطلع منها
الهامات احنا قاعدين على المسرح في شيء
مضايقكم الاضاءه فيها مشكله كيف تقدر
تحسنها الصوت ف مشكله كيف تقدر تحسنه وكل
واحد عنده اكسبيرينس وانا مؤمن بحاجه انه
الله سبحانه وتعالى لما خلقنا ما خلقنا
قوالب كلنا زي بعض او من قالب واحد كل
واحد عنده بصمه عقليه زي ما عنده بصمه في
اصباعه عنده شيء معين هو افضل من العالم
كله فيه لازم يكتشف هذا الشيء هذه وظيفته
ان يكتشف هذا الشيء حط لنفسك
كوز بعدين حط هدف عشان او اهداف مجموعه
اهداف عشان توصل للكوز هذا اشتغل وابحث عن
البصمه هذهه اللي ربنا خلقك عليها عشان
بكره سبحانه بكره بعد عمر طويل لما توفى
وتروح عند الله سبحانه وتعالى تقول له يا
الله انا قدمت لامتي للناس للبشريه لعمار
الارض واحد اين 3
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرا
ه